materials supplied by microsoft
corporation may be used for internal
review analysis or research only any
editing reproduction publication
reproduction internet or public display
is forbidden and may violate copyright
law
good morning everybody we are ready to
start the last day of the workshop it's
my great pleasure to introduce the
invited speaker that started this this
day professor Marcus boo courage who is
going through a professor at the
University of San Paulo professor max
boo courage was a research at institute
of botany for 20 years in San Paulo and
the city of San Paulo he was also a
director a scientific director in CT be
with a national ad for researching bio
ethanol in Campinas it's st. pain he was
one of the founders of the bio end
program of a pass be the best program
for two first studies on bioenergy and
where he was also our coordinator
besides he is one of the few Brazilians
members of IPCC and he is the director
of the NCT of bio ethanol with an
important initiative from the federal
government besides that is a great
friend and its really pleasure to have
someone from the bio bio from the
biocide who is one of the most
enthusiastic people another person I
know on mathematical and computational
methods in order to try to solve
problems on his field thank you very
much max fur for accepting this
invitation
take a Roberto everything that Roberto
said is what the true is really that we
are great friends and Roberto is a great
collaborator of our team I'm a biologist
so I in advance I will I will ask for
forgiveness for some of the naive
mathematics that we'll talk about but
I'm really enthusiastic with that and I
think computational biology is is the
future so first my main core of research
is how plants function plant physiology
and this is a little bit of the history
of plant physiology showing you how
certain techniques and computational
biology is up here completely changed
the way we look at how plants function
how plants work and we are now living in
the indie amex era as you as you all
know we are sequencing genomes complete
genomes looking at expression of genes
and interacting these with metabolomics
as well so the proteomics metabolomics
all this omics mean that we have big
data we have a lot of data to deal with
and how to integrate this data I think
is the main is the main issue in the in
this in this era so we the way to
integrate that is using systems biology
using general system theory so looking
at how the systems integrate each other
and also by doing that we in
understanding how information flows
inside the plant we could do a thing
called synthetic biology that is produce
a plant or an animal that will do things
that they don't not normally would do so
with that it could develop a completely
different technology and maybe in the
future we will have planned plants and
factories plants that will produce the
kind of materials and substances that we
need and even artificial life maybe we
can create
a different way of producing life this
is the first so my talk the goal of
everything that we are doing in my lab
is related to better production of food
to how plants deal with the environment
especially the global climate change how
plants respond to global climate change
and also related to the production of
renewable energy I hope I can show you i
will what I will do is to show some case
studies that I hope I can integrate in
the end so that you will understand how
this connects to to each other so the
flow of information inside the plant is
made primarily by one atom in fact two
atoms there are many of them but carbon
how plants deal with carbon where when
they take carbon co2 from the atmosphere
through photosynthesis where is this
carbon going as this carbon flows
through the plant it tells the organ or
the cell where it is going I'm here and
by telling I am here I'm arriving here
and flowed how much carbon arrives there
will trigger several signals in
different organs that will send some
messages back to other places so if you
if you look carefully plants maybe even
telligent beings right maybe like a
brain that is not centralized a brain
that is exploded but communication is
there and how part of my talk will be
about that well let's quickly look at
this this is the integration of the
plant you have to remember that the main
factors that plants are reading in the
environment are light water co2 and
temperature it reads these all the time
in the atmosphere and also in the soil
in the soil you have the nutrients you
have the water that is coming in and you
have the microorganisms plants
communicate with microorganisms
actually microorganisms leave inside the
plant and exchange information with the
plant this is called endophytic
microorganisms so it's a very very
complex system if you look if you look
carefully the plant itself the body of
the plant is made of cells and tissues
and these tissues are made of molecules
which are made of atoms so the question
is how the scales correlate to each
other inside plants so for example when
a co2 enters the leaf this is one
molecule that can tell lots and lots of
things about how what the tissue in the
root is going to have to do in the next
day or in even in that very night okay
flow of information so say you have a
plant that is reading what is Google
going on in the soil and in the
atmosphere so the plant is receiving
signals right and there is a reception
system and this reception system will
operate by producing for example rnas
rnas are the molecules that are
transcribed from the DNA from the code
the DNA is just the cold the cold is
transcribed to two RNA and RNA is
translated to proteins and the proteins
will operate and make the metabolism you
are now sitting here in your brains are
working because of that right all the
time very quickly everything is
integrating then there is this new issue
that is epigenetics so in fact the
plants are not or the organisms are not
really expressing rnase but they is like
if the DNA is expressing everything but
there is this mechanisms these
mechanisms like epigenetics that are
suppressing the expression of the genes
that are not necessary so this this this
is very interesting new field which is
very important for us if we think of
computing biology but the
the the signal signal transduction
within the plant we can change
development cell fate if the an organ or
the entire plant will leave or die for
example many parts of the plant can die
like a little plant can throw throw out
a leaf or flower so there is life and
death occurring all the time and this is
due to communication so this this ends
up being something that we call
phonology for example we are here in the
in the tropical station all deciduous
forests where the leaves will fall due
to the decrease of temperature and the
decrease of water in the northern
hemisphere you see bye-bye mainly by the
temperature and also because of the lack
of water the leaves will fall but for
different reasons and plants somehow
they know they where they are from is
like if they had a culture for example
right ok information I think you all
know that but this is a biologist view
of that so communication means that you
have you have to have a source of
information that is the as I said
primarily the temperature and in the co2
and water and then you have a message
this message is you you did a
transmitter to transmit this message and
you have interferes interferes in
language can be for example semantics
semantics barriers I can be here telling
you something and because of the
semantics i'm using you you're having
something different in your mind right
that's same semiotics right that's
there's the process of semiosis in the
brain of every one of you could be
different from what what I'm is in my
brain so plants may have sent es mi
haces biological semi haces this is
discussed in the literature the receptor
the signal is received by a receptor and
then it goes to the final destination so
this is the the way I think about
information now if we look
more deeply inside biology this is an
example of how plants in general would
respond to the global climate change so
if if I increase co2 for example this is
just for co2 the plants have this
stomata that I'm thousands and thousands
of little mouses usually in the in the
down side of the leaf that we will open
every morning and allow co2 to enter as
it allows co2 to enter it loses water so
there is a trade-off here and this what
happens here the stomata will open and
the store will open and then the carbon
that the carbon from the co2 will be
transformed into sucrose with sugar and
the sugar will be transport that you
will leave for example and produce this
beautiful grain here that is starch
right it stores a starch or just sense
the sugar to the root and to do other
places in the leaf when we when we put a
plant to grow in elevated co2 what we
see is an increase in photosynthesis the
electron transport system that is the
system that takes light takes the energy
of light and connects the energy this
energy with the processing of the carbon
to produce the sugars will be changed
like it will be improved and then by
doing that the leaf will deal better
with water because if you lose less
water right the stomata can be not so
open and carbohydrate status of the leaf
is better it produces more more sugar
and so on and so forth or respiration
goes up there is all a signal system
that will if the car ball is too much
what the plant is going to do is to
switch off the photosynthesis to
decrease for a sentence you acclimate to
the situation this is one of the things
the other thing and I'll show you what
what a plant can do is to when it
developed where we develop a new leaf
when it is growing and elevated co2 it
can produce a leaf with a lower number
of stomata right so there is a
communication system inside a plant
that's that's why I put that there the
information is the most important
information that I would like to give
you today our lab is called Lafayette oh
the physiological i confuse a laboratory
of plant echo physiology university of
san paulo and we have been dealing with
several different species as i told you
species related to phaseolus vulgaris
for example that is food sugarcane that
is bioenergy soy bean is food or feed
and several species from the atlantic
forest you understand to understand the
biomes and also plans from the amazon as
well like this one here matter pasta
which is bioenergy and as I found that
is food not going what we want to
understand with that and this this is
very important because I have to connect
this later on the mission is to
understand the flux flux of information
inside the plant the variables that we
can change in the laboratory co2 water
and temperature the Technic techniques
that we use are within the domain of the
biochemistry metabolomics and metabolism
of sugars molecular biologists well
measuring gene expression for example
and we deal with native species trying
to understand how plants will respond to
do a changing environment it's not only
global climate change by changing
environment and how to control systems
in the crop in the crop species how to
control systems interaction to apply
this your synthetic biology in the
bioenergy side we there is a project
that we have in the laboratory that is
called the super cane project that we
think that we can now transform the
plant in many different parts so that we
could really make the plunge you work
differently but this is very tricky and
we will need a lot of computational
biology for that i will show you one
example that is the high- occur burial
is a big tree that occurs from the
amazon actually from mexico up to
some follow and to illustrate the
problem i'll show you a film that we
made several years ago we wanted to
understand they showing loop people for
her
when Tova pasando alibi clicker never
personally no so what we wanted to
understand here is very simple thing
what happens here you see that this this
young plant that those are baby plants
seedlings growing so we detach it the
cotyledons and you can see that there is
a big difference in the size of the
plant so we wanted to study these
reserves that is in the cotyledon that
was very simple very simple plant
physiology proximal so physiologically
we can just measure for example the dry
weight of the cotyledon and see that the
dry weight after 40 days will go down
whereas the seedling is growing you can
see that all that in the film but I have
to to put numbers on it for you to
understand another way to look at that
actually look really is to cut the
cotyledon and see that the reserve that
is there and in the cell wall this is
the inside of the cell and this is the
cell wall is eaten by the system and
this is the carbon that makes the plant
grow so this is simple don't physiology
as i promised in my in my my summary
this is the story why we studying this
system it became more and more complex
we ended up looking at the biochemistry
of that and we found that this
polysaccharide this reserve is a
polysaccharide in the wall it doesn't it
doesn't matter the biochemistry for you
but it's just to understand that this
this polymer is degraded by several
different enzymes and will produce free
sugars glucose silos galactose that will
be used for the plant as a source of
carbon to grow then we continue to look
at that and we found for example that it
look this part occurs during the night
and this part occurs during the day
things became more and more complex as
we did that we also
started to look at this the chemical
structure of this polysaccharide and we
actually found that polysaccharides may
have a code just like the DNA and the
proteins and we made we may prove of
that so when we are looking after that
now and we are going to have to use
computer computing biology for that
computational biology for that so we
ended up with this idea that the plant
you have this seedling you have the
seedling growing you have photosynthesis
photosynthesis produce sucrose sucrose
is also produced by the cotyledons co2
is entering their so during the day what
is happening is that photosynthesis is
working right and we found one of these
signals that is this is a debts a plant
hormone that is sent by by the planted
by the leaves is sent to the cotyledon
saying I'm growing I'm growing send me
sucrose okay this is the message that
this is saying then during the day this
is almost disappeared so the plant is
using photosynthesis and during the
night during the night photosynthesis is
obviously not on so sucrose is not going
and the plant is communicating mostly
with the cotyledons this is a plant that
eats carbon 24 hours a day right instead
of using just photosynthesis and this is
the reason why this plants grow so fast
we have now another plant from the
Amazon that we are working with that
produces siblings that are these this
size because they grow very very quickly
because they use these sugars to escape
flooding in the Amazon when the flooding
is coming for example so we ended up
with that and it became more and more
complex right so we have a biochemistry
all these signaling all the signaling
mechanisms we found that red light is
involved
blue light is involved not only not only
the photosynthetic light many we found
many of the genes related so we started
to see this network becoming more and
more complex it's difficult we also grew
these plants in elevated co2 we have
these chambers in our laboratory that is
we can increase the co2 we double the
concentration of co2 you can see the
high menia the jatoba growing growing
inside of co2 and we found a few things
you can imagine that I have a literally
hundreds and hundreds of data on that so
I'm just showing you a few of them
myself a la Bravo say bye next please
yeah one thing that we found is one
thing that we found is that the plants
seem to become obese when they grow in
elevated co2 they they have much more
starch as you see here to the point that
the gate they can even destroy some of
the chloroplasts so this is a symptom of
the global climate change that could be
quite important in the future possible
then we we also grew in elevated
temperature and you can see that when
you combine elevated temperature with
elevated co2 the plant will grow even
faster even faster right next you
remember that a co2 is going here you
remember that I told you that plants
will decrease the stomata when they grow
in elevated co2 they enter here this is
the down part of the leaf and this is
the where they cut the chloroplasts are
and the surface of the leaf Brussels so
we we found that the stomata is really
decreasing when when we we put the
plants in elevated co2 then we started
to imagine that well if this is
happening now when I make the experiment
it's possible that this is already
happening since the beginning of the
20th century and we look at four leaves
that were were collected in nineteen
in nineteen nineteen nineteen in 1929
presume Russell and what we found is
that really there were much more some
water in the past then there is now when
we look at that 1929 prossimo we found
this so stomata is already decreasing
and this is already a symptom of plant
the plant is reading the environment
since the beginning of the 20th century
now we have a five species including
this one and four for this one we
already have a collection made in 1870
so we want to see what was going on
there next so looks like plants may be
intelligent right because they are
reading the environment in a long term
in a short-term every day they 24 hours
or even in minutes plant can change the
behavior depending on the environment so
I started to look at the definitions of
intelligence so acquaintances
intercourse familiarity information
communicated new use notice this is from
from English dictionary right i think
it's calling as i don't remember who it
is the capacity to know and understand
readiness your comprehension etc etc
it's linked to humans but people that
define intelligence they are very
careful to define intelligence so that
is not only human intelligence is wider
than human so i started to think whether
plants could be intelligent and then one
idea was to look at the proximal was to
look at mathematics and see artificial
intelligence what what these guys in
artificial intelligence were talking
about so and i started to read i
stumbled in this book that is
fascinating for me from john holland
that's called emergence and then he uses
very simple in the beginning very very
simple example of a chess-playing for
example that you have a different
strategies and you have an evaluator of
this strategy and you have a predictor
of distraction of the strategy and then
you
of a selector and you choose another
strategy so that you have gained the
game happening next if you look now an
artificial intelligence this is another
thing that we found if you look at an
artificial neuron it obeys the habs law
so as higher the stimulation their own
we will be stimulated until it gets into
fatigue okay so if I have for example
two inputs input 1 and input 2 and the
output and if I look the company you
look at the combination of the two
inputs and what is the output I would
have this outputs here okay very lazy
mind if now I have three neurons instead
of one and I have two inputs again and
these neurons interact the output would
change in this position for it so so
that's fine if plants work it like that
could be intelligence however if you
take this output possible if you take
this output and use this as a source of
input then you see something that in a
very simple way that is memory so I
asked myself would plants have memory
and we try to do some experiments
brother first if plants had memory they
would be able to recognize patterns as
we actually see in nature right how John
Holland says we recognize patterns we
don't see the whole we see for example
in a triangle we would see the vertices
of the triangle so that we first see a
and then we see B and then we see see
and then we eliminate the interactions
in then we know that is a triangle so
it's a very simple way of looking and
save that in your mind looking just as
certain things i should be able blunt
should be able to recognize a pattern
prosser so we we started doing some
neural networks for example we did an
experiment with Jaime near measuring
photosynthesis twice per week during a
year and in collaboration with the
polytechnics next please oprah sao paulo
right so using the neural networks we
discovered that we came forecast what
will be the photosynthesis within a year
with ten percent error in relation we
separated the data like people do and
with the fuzzy logic when we applied
fuzzy logic we go to five percent right
so this this is intelligent but it is
interesting by itself and these
connections that plants made I was
trying to think of a theory of
formalization for that and I came up
with this thing that I call connection
firing mechanism this this is this would
be the basic mechanism for environmental
semi semi haces the environment has
variables that are connected to
metabolism and these variables are this
light temperature water in co chiu and
gene expression enzyme action molecular
action will give will determine the
behavior of the plant so you look at the
memory we knew that the plant behave
when photosynthesis behaving in a way
that I can forecast what is going to
happen but there is memory if a plant
for example that's that's not time in
year that's a policy it's a symbol of
the country that gave the name of Brazil
if I take one plant and put this plant
inside the forest where it cannot see
the full light but it has all the
complications of all the leaves that are
moving right I have something that you
can see here when you see light here the
blue it's called some flack in a certain
time the Sun will cross and will go to
for example from zero you go to five
hundred micro moles per square meter per
second of light so there is a train of
waves that we arrive in the surface of
the leaf right so there is one train
here another train here another train
here
if now we look at the photosynthesis in
the first strain that is quite high
plant will not respond when the second
train arrives right there will be a huge
response and then after that plant the
plants understood that this is this is
coming changed the proteins in the
surface and synchronized photosynthesis
with the environment so is this a
decision mechanism is these intelligence
we don't know okay plants may have a
memory do they have a language if they
kept can we read what plant is saying
usually women can do that right in the
house they can look at the plant and say
you need water and then now you need
more light let me move you write this
this sounds strange for us men but this
is not strange because they can really
use their intuition to see things that
maybe we cannot and we scientists main
scientists not women science but men
scientists will have to develop
mathematics and computational biology to
understand the language that you can
easily you can easily see language then
I started interested to be interested in
language so language is very very
interesting this this this paper from
this guy's Ricard Soleil from Barcelona
is a fantastic scientist and he works a
lot with these networks of language so
you have a network here if you take for
example this text here from Virginia
Woolf and you you just you construct a
network and this network is based on on
on the precedence so what are the
highest the pieces in the texts that are
more important in terms of being linked
it to everybody if you if you do that
use the degree centrality I will explain
degree centrality later if you use the
degree centrality to see that you see
that the
particles like a d etc are the more the
most important particles in the text but
you can also construct a semantic
semantic network instead of using the
degree centrality use another centrality
that is called between the centrality
which measures the flow of information
inside network and then when you do that
you see that the verbs become more
important but you can use degree in
between it and the other centrality
still look at the language and this the
paper is really fascinating you can you
can for example this semantic networks
can can be built like this for example
you can have hypo in high piranhas me
for example a rose here roses is a hypo
name of a flower and the flower is a
high puranam of rose so you can
construct a network like this so that
you wouldn't read the semantics and see
much better the semantics of the network
then you see with the between us and
with the degree centrality the
conclusion that required gets is that
language is between that mean if you
have a word a semi semi he means Emma
which is the origin of the words and
semiotics is a meaning imagine that you
have an object here and you have several
different words for this object so it's
very hard for the listener to understand
what I'm talking about unless I have
very many words right so as language
developed in humans what happened what
happens is that the words acquired not
so many meanings but a few meanings and
these few meanings make much easier for
the listener to understand on the other
hand if I start to talk to you just like
our scientists here I start to talk to
you words that have very specific
meanings it gets harder and harder for
you to understand what I'm talking about
so communication is based on on this
equilibria
and the evolution of language is that my
question is where plants when plants
read the environment temperature water
light and they behave can I find in the
metabolites in the genes in the behavior
something that will be words that have
meaning if they do if they do is they
exist well where is the plant here it's
here or is there we tend to think we
humans don't you think that the plants
are here but they're done right that
they don't have any language they don't
express anything I don't believe that
now another thing so leave this window
open and we come back to it bioenergy
and sugarcane at the same time we were
studying sugarcane so co2 enters the
leaf is a different leaf from from the
high- year co2 enters the leaf and we
produce this sugar just quickly going we
put it we put that plant in elevated co2
and then it grows more and produces
thirty percent more biomass produces
more sugar so the plant is much better
so it's spreading the sugar inside the
plant in the form of sucrose this is
what we want we want more bioenergy and
we look at the genes and when we look at
the genes we see obviously that
photosynthesis is a secondary metabolism
is up so many different systems are are
perturbed by expressing more genes or
highly expressing some of the genes that
are already expressed or suppressing the
expression of other genes metabolism
also change so again the search is for
the words in the plant language you can
get to that Amanda Amanda got to that in
her PhD so you can see all the network
of community of communication among
different things like if you have for us
when you put a plant in elevated co2
increase for the synthesis of the
is my late you increase these nadp mdh
and then the genes for transport of
electrons and electrons are up so when
the genes it doesn't matter what is
going on here for now what matters is
that when I Plitt plant an elevated co2
it increases the antenna to capture more
light and because it does that it sucks
more carbon co2 and produce more sugar
so can I in terms of synthetic biology
can I change that here we already have
four genes that are are in the way for
to be fully fully sequenced or found in
the genome of sugarcane that we are
going to transform to see whether we can
increase photosynthesis and deal with
the system on the other hand we can also
deal with growth in different ways
looking at the sugars the accumulation
of starch etc etc one thing that is
important as well is that sorry the
plant this is the plant in the long term
this is a 75 days 75-day experiment but
if you look at the plant in the 24 hours
then you see other things so in fact
this is the integration of several
different 24 hours and we usually have a
lot of information in the leaves and not
so much information in the same and in
the root if we want to understand the
systems we would need to look at the
entire plan chilean to look the
communication and the entire plant and
this is this we have already date on
that so in the end integration of the
scales is very important so the
information the information is storage
and processing in this equation is based
on the genes that are there how these
genes are expressed may proteins may
metabolize these metabolites will
integrate themselves in chains that are
the proteins are put in a certain place
at a certain time in under certain
conditions that will process things like
metabolic pathways to produce energy
choose to use
energy and then you have this functional
modules that are several different
systems that will make functions life
when I say a function is a
photosynthesis the route is absorbing
nutrients the transport system of
sucrose whatever it's all systems and
these systems have also to connect among
themselves right and they they will be
like phrases in a text and and the red
and the blue here could be the words
that are linked and they there is
enlarged even a larger scale
organization in the ecosystem that you
have other types of functions well
organisms and most of the networks in
known are hierarchical networks and
biology if we look for example at
saccharomyces cerevisiae that's for you
to relax this is beer right the beer or
bread if you want you can see that the
transcription system the metabolic
system and the protein system are all
hierarchical networks I'll show you
better what is a hierarchical network if
you look now at the data that we collect
in photosynthesis it obeys the same law
it also it also can be constructed as a
as a hierarchical network so this is the
kind of data that we get but there's
much more than that and especially if
you put the genes on but this just the
physiology this for you to have a look
at the physiological parameters we use
35 of them we need shoes is the guy that
is working on that together with Amanda
so you have classes you have here the
biomass of the leaf of the comb this is
sugar cane right then you have all the
photosynthetic parameters the sugars in
green here the all the the light
harvesting system here this is the
carbon harvesting system this is the
light harvesting system and this is the
atomic level how much nitrogen der is
how much carbon Ares what can I make
with that the method that we have been
using we have developing ourselves up to
now we take a
full experiment for 75 days and we want
to make one single image that could
represent the entire experiment in the
behavior of the plant using network so
what we do is we we make correlations
pair two pair all these parameters 30 35
variables and then we we use these
statistics and we use a p-value we cut
it with a p-value and then we establish
a link based a link between two
parameters will be based on statistical
robustness that we can choose what it is
so for example if I take carbon carbon
nitrogen for example the percentage of
nightly correlate with the percentage of
nitrogen I'll make the Pearson's
correlation and now have the p-value
here that is that and so on and so forth
oh here i have I chosen eval use to be
the ones that I want to see and these
red p values for me they are no good
there are no correlation so then I make
the links and I exclude these links and
I maintain the links that have the
correlation so I come up with something
like this right I have all the
parameters here complicated still what
where should I look at the way to look
at is to look at the centrality like I
said in the name like like I said we
were selected in the language for those
of you that don't understand what the
centrality take for example the last
supper right if you want to understand
the last supper you have the degree
centrality Jesus will receive links from
Peter James Judah and Matthew right so
the highest degree centrality in this
network would be Jesus with for leakages
ok 44 links and peter peter 3 links is
an impor
certain guy as well Matthew and other
three links could be looking at the
picture okay very precise I'm not so
precise here talking in general but now
if I if I this is the degree centrality
now if I look for example who is more
important if I want to get to Jesus who
is the best friend of Jesus spitter
right so everyone here that would like
to get to Jesus would talk for a su
Peter so Peter has higher between the
centrality in relation to Jesus so it's
a very important guy as well there are
many other central t's but this is just
an example so if I want to understand
who is attracting more links like in the
language the particles a and D the
articles are are the most important or
if I want to understand semantics if I
want to understand better semantics i
can go to between us right this is this
is the this is what i said before so now
if we look at the centrality for example
between the centrality of the network
for sugarcane in a 75 day experiment so
in red here you have the highest between
the centrality in ambient co2 and in
elevated co2 and you see the plant
changes here it has the GS that is the
opening or not the stomata so the plant
is dealing which means that the plant is
dealing with water right it doesn't
matter the other calls because I don't
have time to explain here but look just
at the betweenness centrality is the
degree centrality is the grid centrality
zar the the level of transparency that
you see in the network here and but net
then if I if I elevate the co2 the plant
will start to focus on the height and
biomass just like I see the behavior in
my experiment ok so this we don't know
yet but this seems we are still working
on that we are trying to apply with
Roberto leave one out and all the
techniques to to check the robustness of
that but the robustness the statistical
robustness is ok for now
but I told you also that the plant is
another one during one day and this this
is a very nice example of the same plant
and you can see here this is a if it's
photosynthesis a sugarcane planter in
one day this is during the day the gray
here is during the night so you can see
that photosynthesis obviously is up
during the day and down during the night
but you can see here this is the starch
it builds the starch and as the night
comes it will degrade the starch and use
and this is Rafi rose and sucrose that
is the most important thing in sugarcane
you see that sucrose pics in the leaves
and then decreases this is leaf stem
stem and root so you're now looking at
the entire plant and we can see more so
this is where the big data start to
coming this is this is 91 metabolites
that I can see in in all the cells in
the leaves in the stem and in the cone
right so what this is this tells me this
graph here tells me somehow what's going
on inside ourselves if we can look at
that in this way I can construct little
clocks and see what's going on at every
different hour looking at the substances
and I see that cellulose metabolism is
there in the afternoon synthesis of
hemicellulose during the day cell
expansion during the night this is in
the leaf but this is different in roots
right in this stem in this experiment
this this was not read yet but we have
accumulation of sucrose and the decrees
of sucrose and glucose etc so here we
can see that there might be signaling
systems which is probably related to
sugar transport that is signaling among
organs so one organ is talking actually
to each other through this signals that
are producing depending on the
metabolism ok so if I look at now with
the network of the metabolism I'll see
thing
like this and the network and I can see
that the link looking at positioning the
nodes that are more linked to the other
on the basis of degree centrality I can
see that here the leaves in green and
the root is in red and in blue is the
stem so we can see that they really
separate that are more connected you can
see different connectivities levels of
connectivities among Gorgas this is
obvious right but we can we can actually
see metabolically what kind of metal
metal isms the different organs have and
they are actually different right they
are not the same because this this nodes
here not the same thing there are
different things and I can see here
degree centrality is an amino acid and I
can see the betweenness centrality
centrality that's a strange thing this
is Manos which is related to the
synthesis of proteins for example then I
can look at the night metabolisms and
look at the centrality the centrality in
the night is one is different from the
general centrality still amino acids and
synthesis of protein but there is a bias
here because this is what I measure and
then this is where we are now we are
trying to understand that and how we can
use that to understand the behavior of a
full experiment looking at the
metabolism and looking at the physiology
but there is one problem how this levels
communicate how metabolism communicates
with physiology which communicates the
different organs so we for the microsoft
research for PES project we chose
sorghum why because sorgen servant is an
important feed in bioenergy the genome
is completely sequenced
it has a simple genetics it's just a
diploid genome the genome is similar to
sugarcane so I can extrapolate the
sugarcane and use for bioenergy and for
food as well it closes the life cycle in
relatively short time about four months
the plaintiff sorghum will flower and
produce seeds so i could add another
dimension to the experiments that i
couldn't add for sugarcane and for hi
minion because for high menia to wait
for a flower and a seed will take 35
years for sugarcane it takes about a
year here in four months I can close the
cycle and I can understand not only the
not only the talk between the organs but
also along the development and how
pregnant plant behaves if it changes the
language when it becomes pregnant right
so the idea in our project is is that is
that we would we would look at different
levels the inter scale levels and the
interest K levels in leaves stem and
root and try to connect that this is not
trivial and this is where the big data
come from come come come in the game
right because we are going to have about
one or but maybe three million sequences
of RNA now we can measure 400 molecules
in the metabolomics at a time 500 so we
are going to have 1500 or at least 10
times more metabolomics than you saw
before in these networks so what kind of
mathematics or what kind of computing by
computing science that we are going to
to use in this case so we started the
experiment what we have in lafayette CO
is we are increasing more and more the
the sensors that we have in you can see
here that we can measure different
things like measuring about
photosynthesis we can we can actually
measure how much water there is in the
soil and what the water is going down
the idea of the experiment with
organ is to take water out in a certain
point and see how it how the plant will
respond when and it doesn't have water
and has higher co2 which is the scenario
that we expect for climate change so
this for you to have an idea we change
we change the plants and we look at
every leaf when every leaf appears this
is 80 days experiment this is a
preliminary experiment that is already
going on and we can see we are checking
everything what is the level of
photosynthesis of every leaf of the
plant is the stomata open in every leaf
of the plant this is just preparing
things we can see the the height of the
plant increasing here here we suspended
water and we are seeing what happens of
obviously the height becomes the same it
stays the same and they said this is an
example of the sensor for example when I
suspended the water from the face this
records for me the water going down
whereas here you can see when I add
water every time I what I add water in
what happens in the vase this is what
happens in your house right when you
read about our water if you don't add
water the plants will die because it
goes here and there is this very
interesting bumps here that is that the
plant during the night will take some of
the water from the atmosphere and
actually water the soil its own soil
right since this is a very nice
phenomenon that was recently discovered
so the basic idea of our project is in
fact it's a very challenging is that we
use these three variables water
temperature and co2 and look at them at
different organs and then different
tissues and cells if possible it is
already possible to look at the
redundant the redundance of cells so see
if a tissue is responding differently or
not we can cut this with a laser and
look at the gene expression metabolism
etc and then integrate in this so
this this is the basic the basic idea I
don't know what kind of mathematics
there's very very little in the
literature about scale interaction we
find I found very very little so we
probably will need the help of
mathematics not only computing science
and mathematics as well and then apply
this to develop develop visualization
systems that can drive us to understand
better what's what's in there these are
the collaborators Roberto Roberto is
part of that and our guard angel since
the beginning has been Julian I don't
know if you Liana is here I didn't I
didn't see here yeah yesterday but
without without Giuliana without
Giuliana we wouldn't have the project
because she was really very keen with
the idea and help it as a lot since the
beginning making very very interesting
questions from from a lay person because
she's not from from biology and help it
as a lot to develop the project so
that's it and you you may contact me if
you if you can help me please with
something on the computing science and
mathematics thank you very much
okay we have time for some questions
first of all I'm fascinating with
fascinated with with your work we have a
growing school in Columbia and metabolic
rate constructions and topological
analysis and flux violence analysis of
metabolic networks and in in in
especially in land pathogen interactions
so my question goes in that direction
since you're trying to evaluate or to
see how the different variables climatic
variables affect the plan development
and and so on and the if I didn't
misunderstood your your presentation
what you're doing is trying to figure
out how these variables affect that
communication process between different
organs and organs and it's it's more the
clocks of information so my question is
have you have you or you have in mind to
approach the same problem but looking at
the metabolism itself I mean that has
these flux of information in the
metabolism as a whole I mean how my
chocolate a goes to metabolites be
through some reaction by means of a
metabolic reconstruction based on Gina
genomic scale or perhaps a transcriptome
scale made a bunch of reconstruction did
you have these in your pants or how do
you think that you're speaking about
phase transition in the system right
metabolic phase transition yeah actually
with with with it with a huge amount of
information you have it could be a lot
of things you have a lot of information
for instance you have 35 articles and
you also have
information or differential expression
information for several time points as I
could see it could be a dynamic study of
the metabolic phenotypes for each stage
yeah that could be faced incision or it
could be a study of the dynamic of the
of the evolution of the network through
the time of flux of the information to
the network to the time well what we are
trying to do is to provoke the plant
using this system that we have if you
give more co2 because co2 is so
important for a plant so I was talking
about phase transition because you have
a status emit metabolic phenotype if you
want and during during one day because
we have to look at you have to integrate
the plant in one day because the plant
is it's an organism so phase transition
what I meant by that is that when I
provoke the plant changing the
temperature change in co2 I will what
what kind of changes in the semantics of
the communication among organs in your
case microorganism and the end the plant
what kind of changes in the semantics
what I what I believe could be helpful
as I said in the beginning from my naive
point of view is that the centrality
could be a very nice way to see just
like we're seeing language if we if we
can pinpoint this this things that are
more important than others from
different angles maybe we can sort of
clean all the this data and look at the
most important meaningful data that the
plant is using to communicate this
doesn't mean that we wouldn't need to
produce all these data right because if
I don't produce this data I don't I
don't have access to the to the degree
centrality between the centrality in
close and close the centrality so we
have to continue to produce data in the
different temples
hello I'm from computer science and you
say that you you need help to compute
the sum some things you know it's not
clear or for us I believe but it's a
common practice on computer science and
you share data sets and it I believe it
sec is that also good idea how do you
say that that simple betweenness Koreans
and drug degree is some kind similar to
complex network and heck of a decision
like in the facebook to recommend a
friend and sometimes is hard in computer
science to find a data set that could be
useful so the same data set is the is
used for thousands of students and the
against stays on a thousand of papers
and you can't contribute another another
address because you don't have the data
set and even see if you it's a good idea
to share the data set and the X now it's
put a paper the data set on the side and
say what's the target and I believe that
a lot of people can help just doing a
Chopin good useful this will be great
what we have i presented just a very
small part of the data we have we have
already studied 15 species so we have a
huge amount of data that we are trying
to organize together with Roberto in the
nap system and the products Roberto is
the coordinator of this project at
Universal some power of computing
science applied to biology and the idea
that we have we are preparing because we
biologists are sort of disorganized with
data right we produce lots of these
spreadsheets and things and we leave it
in the computer and then as was said
yesterday they could be the version is
with disappears and then you get crazy
and go to a computer science you recover
that so the idea is the offer of the
integration that we have beauty sighs in
biology at universe for some families
that we would put this data in in such a
way that we could share that with others
artists and get more and more flat so in
the future maybe we could look at the
betweeners rd between assists of the
network's metabolic networks of the
amazon different from the atlantic
forest our soy being different from
sugarcane looking at this these
experiments and these behaviors that's
but this is this is this is really you
are absolutely correct oh we have
to share that if you want you to evolve
our seamless was a great talk as usual
um I noticed that in your chain of
interactions even though you kind of
mentioned them you did not talk about
humans in the sense that plants will
react differently according to the way
I'm not talking about the way they are
treated because you talked about women
will talk to plants and the man will
ignore them it's not going to me but the
way I don't know how to say that in
English but manager ok so the way you
measurement you treat management we
treat the soil you protect the plant
from San whatever so how does kind of
interaction enter in your studies in our
studies for the time being we don't we
don't have that I'm starting to study
that on the bioenergy side we are
starting to to do some work on the
decision making and bioenergy which has
something indirectly related indirectly
in a very nice way indirectly related to
what is going on in the field and all
these metabolisms but we did we didn't
think but this scale will be very
important I don't know maybe some
somebody in the audience can help but
maybe there are a lot well did the
systems general Systems Theory what is
really says bertalanffy 1950 says is
that there are laws there you have we
have the laws of the physics and the
chemistry but when you go to biology
sociology and
atmospheric sciences you there are new
laws that physics doesn't have that
that's the system small so I think by
looking at the scales if at this K we
could discover some details of these
laws how it's working maybe we could
apply to the other laws and then I think
the interaction with the work you do for
example with these interactions would be
much easier that's my hope I'm
fascinated by things you talked about in
your experiments with elevated co2 and
sorghum sorghum is I mean biologists
also silly things like very simple
things like C elegans so sorghum is
clearly much more complex than that but
you do have the genomic information and
you you can look at the leaves the
plants and the roots stems and the roots
what would be the goal when you
understand this would you would you be
able to do some genetic engineering or
synthetic biology with it is that your
ultimate goal I forgot to mention in
fact the tube to persons on the bottom
of my slide are Elena carrere and an
hour long so anna is a metabolic
engineer at Ohio State University and
Elena is our transformer person in the
in the project in the I NCT it so we are
now sending next Monday a proposal to
get some money to to work together and I
is going to do the metabolomics and
transcriptomics will be done with marie
anne from slowest so that having the
genes our idea is to use sorghum I think
sorghum will probably go together with
sugar cane into the synthetic biology so
the idea is really to find this systems
look at the between us look at the genes
that are related to the between us the
meta meta Bala metabolites and the genes
that are related to the between this
between us Azure degrees and then try to
change these genes to see if we can
change the semantics your communication
networks with between this and
centrality is that related to metabolic
pathways oh yeah sure yeah some of them
the that's why I show the metabolic
network here because we you can
transform that in metabolic pathways so
this would be very tricky because we
have to if we look at the centrality
what kind of transformation we will have
to use engineering skills in fact to see
what kind of transformation we have we
can make that will change the behavior
of the plant without killing it or
avoiding that it grows sounds
fascinating can I pick up on that if you
look at the genes in a high betweenness
with high between this is it isn't it
true although I'm not a biologist that
these would be influencing more than one
process more than one metabolic pathway
at once because they are in between
different pathways and you change those
you are changing a lot of things in the
plant at once and wouldn't it be
interesting to see the low betweenness
ones and see if particular processes can
be changed I don't know one at a time
maybe or ten at a time sorry it's just
mind your view on top of some of the
work in biology we are also exploring
we're choosing choosing the betweeners
will be within this this engineering
engineering skills that we have to use
because for example if I take we already
know that if you take for example rapid
opsys a rabid opsys you find full
collections of mutants but there are
certain genes that there is no mutant
why I think because they're very high
between us or high degree so if you if
you this mutant does not exist because
it does not exist because you just cut
communication inside plant so
looking at the scales of the centrality
not only closeness could be quite
important to look other other centrality
'he's will be very important to look but
then i'm not talking about that because
then you would i would have to even draw
it to draw a plant and see well the
closeness will be how you get there
faster not only the communication so i
believe that looking at these i believe
now that looking at the centrality and
you are absolutely correct we can try
not only the low between us but all the
change the chain of between is's and
other centrality to look I think what we
have that is can can be quite nice is
this way of doing in experiments because
very few people i know very few people
or no no people actually that do
experiments like we do every experiment
we do for example sadie full cycles for
months like we are going to do in
sorghum the four month and then we do
the four month and then we do two
crosses that i say 24 hours and we have
all these data we know the name of every
plant as you said as you saw we know the
name of every plant so that we can come
back to data and we would have
spreadsheets that could be shared and if
he is using my data he probably could go
there and even look at a picture of the
plant to see or a film or something like
this so this is this is the idea of
looking at the system when we transform
and take down our centrality then we
could we should be able to look at the
systems then you could design
visualization systems that will be
really fantastic i think sure yet you're
welcome my questions maybe we we can
conclude there is a coffee break now
thank you very much marcos